yeah if you want it do it execute see
I'm so optimistic
boy I'm that college day dreamer just
trying to make enough to see myself drop
in the Beamer you see some spittin
verses that are hotter than a fever all
my music tends to be on the tight end
like a receiver
[Music]
I'm sana pass my classes but doing that
and making music go it's easy plastics I
struggle for my passions especially with
all the artists out here ten hours in
the air for 15 hours of commuting
for a one-hour talk but Facebook is the
platform that
we continue to triple down on it trying
to really think a lot more about impact
versus volume this year this one taught
at a bunch of important meetings seven
eight different meetings in New York but
this one I feel will have a lot of
impact because I give it a lot of people
around you too and it'll be a spark and
a gateway drug for us to collect it now
that I have the office of the CEO I can
scale all those opportunities so just
try to do much more strategic about
every [ __ ] minute
see I could be the best but being the
best doesn't define success success is
working hard and playing less so I'm
never getting the brass she wants me I'm
gonna post a press has some stress see I
can have the talent but that can turn
the self-entitlement and big ego so
easily if I allow it so help keep me
grounded
people try to overthink everything
that I just came up with you know
business never doing it here's the king
of me here is actually that's it you
nailed it I don't give a [ __ ] if bizdev
Sundays works or not it fell right at
the time we're gonna execute it right
now I'll get some dividends from it
anything from zero to life-changing
right manor toys lost money Wine Library
TV changed my career right yeah actually
the more I think about it like like the
amount of things that I you know Vader
toys doesn't work you know while every
TV changes my career Jesus go me chat
didn't work askgaryvee search engine
crushing and could be way bigger we just
haven't done a good job promoting it you
know so yeah I mean I think the reason
most people are losing is because
they're scared of losing that's the
punchline I just don't give a crap
just don't care about other people's
opinions on my entrepreneurial ventures
everybody else does leave I allow it so
help keep me grounded
but keep me lifted cuz a lot of Sun my
shoulders and I need your help to lift
it so I'm carrying my team now I'm
carrying my city away even though it's
been a half hour taking the garbage out
this morning and that's what we do right
right I take the garbage out
you have to Co takes out the garbage
think there's no biggest feel that's
really do everything Johnny what I'm
doing right now in DM is insane hitting
people and DM I'm gonna change I think
listen to this I'm usually putting
headstrong I think there's been four or
five suggestions of calling it crushing
it and then leave crushed it for the end
I'm probably gonna do that I'm being
sold on it it's in the middle yeah she's
got a DM from somebody says I love your
daily be it made me respect to where I
am in the journey
and never ever need to take any step or
victory for granted and just getting my
hands dirty it's fun right because a lot
of kids think they've made it or a lot
of kids haven't even made it yet and
they watch this and they don't take the
[ __ ] 15 hour commute for one meeting
that they can be strategic and that you
know they don't grind and putting in
perspective what it takes that has
always been my biggest goal with this
60-second Club don't forget to like the
photo as well too many we just posting
your check-in now they cheat
[ __ ]
nobody with my son
somebody somebody did their homework
that's my jam a couple things to address
right away first I want to thank my mom
for that first bio that you read number
two I don't think I'm provocative at all
that would be the basis of my talk I
actually think when people say I'm
provocative or a futurist or disruptive
I genuinely believe that I'm the most
practical of all I always start the
meeting with my clients listen you need
to be in the know business instead of
the yes business so we show you [ __ ] you
need to say oh my god no like you can't
put pics in the video not that's not
that adjective is a none brand or that
color is like this magical on-brand [ __ ]
is the funniest thing I've ever seen in
my life it is literally literally the
thing people love the most because again
it's all they've got I mean do you know
what a brand manager in America looks
like they went to business school their
P&L driven their most fun is hanging out
with you when they get to do the
creative thing and the only leverage
they have is to say not funny enough so
they play that card it has nothing to do
with the reality of business guys for
every just do it and every MasterCard
priceless tons of all-time great pieces
of content hit the cutting room floor
because the creative director came in
and said you know what we only have an
hour and a half so instead of four let's
pitch these two he [ __ ] up that third
one would have been it or they come in
with those two and the person picks the
other one I mean it's just not efficient
in a 20-17 world so yes if I could get
them there and they're scared shitless
of this but unlike you guys where you
have to pander to the situation I
literally don't give a [ __ ] if we lose
the business I mean it like the only
reason we've been able to cut through is
I'm like cool see ya
like I don't know like we have to do it
our way there's no ROI positive for me
to [ __ ] do it the other way nobody
watches a [ __ ] television commercial
nobody on earth like when are we gonna
put common sense into the equation the
best deal in the world in marketing the
Super Bowl ad cuz it is event viewing
the worst feel whether it's the Oscars
or Grammys I don't even pay attention I
don't even allow myself to spend one
second to do this homework because it
means nothing for my future but whatever
the second most expensive commercial is
let's call it the Oscar the Grammys the
worst deal in advertising nobody's
watching a commercial during the Oscars
it's not it's not event-driven watching
everybody is commenting on the person's
dress we lack common sense in our
industry bless you we lack common sense
in this industry we lack common sense in
this industry the end the end
here's what I know and this is what
pisses me off I go and do these things I
go - can I get on I'm part of a panel
with the creative director of this
horseshit crated record of that
horseshit and creative director of this
work [ __ ] I do my thing they all team up
with [ __ ] data and then that's it
then we go to the Carlton at 3 o'clock
in the morning and drink rose' and you
pump them with a couple bottles of ROS a
and then they come over and be like
you're right I promise you this one
thing
if people's lives depended on it the way
I marketed for my family business and I
had to feed my family
if people's lives depended on these
decisions they wouldn't be doing what
they're doing I really appreciate the
guy the work you guys are doing I hope I
get to cross paths with a bunch of you
[Applause]
[Music]
choose a team yeah easily you're gonna
be there 125 minutes yeah what easy
squeeze it good move all calls
you just see what I did touch my ear did
you catch that you need guys that's how
much I feel these are a part of me now
like I had to touch my ear to see if
they were in that's crazy right that was
very weird
I mean robots are taking over I'm trying
to tell everybody I do not regret never
never meant
boy watch your mouth this legal paper
store really early wake up and I still
be ready
tell me spit that fetes hate me sm
awareness lately all these rumors and
that comparison did I spit that rim and
give a message they feel pull my heart
out and let your haters clean up what I
spill [ __ ] weed I got your flesh so it's
my new rallying cry more more more just
more right more like whatever you're
doing is more that's what I figured out
actually that's what's really populated
go ahead it's more and more more like
work like that looks great worse it's
becoming a family like like meditation
great more like wanting to your
government more like whatever it is it's
just more and more more like that's my
advice
actually that captures my advice like
make the [ __ ] t-shirt right now hit
up the team that's what I want hashtag
Wars
dudes pants and [ __ ] awesome
it said of throwing I must say as little
bit book but from footsteps - door
buzzes could have wound up injected exit
welfare rearrange the words to my
landlord farewell man that was poor for
this give Ramona sness memories that I
won't forget swampy for you it's good
finished last they don't exist
I'm shred have life at my winning streak
buffet masses place look good [ __ ] what
be rich for free no rest you know sleep
meeting you'll need some irises with our
Aryan eating out because of what we've
been doing with him the amount of people
that follow me that do what you guys do
when there was the wines and that's one
thing basically told me to bloggers and
all these individual producing content
from the camera for online people to
follow us
[Music]
it seems that I go to visit in someone
inventor your lack of chases the
finishing radish in the pickup and do
I bet let me give that color trip I'm in
agreement that this duster broke and
then later later picture listen as I
draw something funny I strip better yet
you only get better
he left us through this on me because he
said I needed to do a hey good night
closeout scene
[Music]
Giusti rock from the back Instagram what
up done with my commute to what the San
Francisco for an hour we really he went
to San Francisco for an hour you know
3000 peeps I'm here to rock uh-huh not
too shabby yeah dese nuts DeSimone was
busy I was in three hours hitting up
random people giving away t-shirts like
make sure you're part of the 60-second
Club because I was just going through
three hours of anybody who left a
comment just DMing random people saying
hello peeps were super pumped guys
taking a selfie with Shake Shack I love
it that's some good content right there
never baby 24/7 365 that's how I do it
nope 24/7 that's my number dog good to
see you would he fire me if I put a
picture of Brady over your office
tomorrow
yes dunk I would in a heartbeat by the
way too like no hesitation like happily
take care Danka I get it man your
morning capable to go do it on yourself
you couldn't wait to get fired I agree
pika good good content what's going on
here I'm a Jets fan who lives in Atlanta
that's the worst my sneaks well with
some good ones today
the white on green you know I wore the
wedding green today
those are my Jets sneakers not just what
I wanted to do today it was a crazy day
do you guys follow the narrative today
do you guys see you guys see what the
[ __ ] it was up to you today commuted to
San Francisco for an hour you ever did
you ever think you're gonna do that
d-roc the wake up at 4 a.m. to spend an
hour and see Francisco be back we have
Ontario this week little Canadian love
you can forward to that
oh and and your best friend Casey is
gonna be there yeah Casey speaking of
that of it love you
see ya keep grindin gonna try to do more
live sessions that was fun my arms tired
though I've been working out all right
now I'm saying it official goodbye
goodbye I love you